spectacle avec véronique sanson jusqu'à
dimanche vous pourrez l'applaudir au
palais des sports
yauba grégoire la rencontrer et sur
scène et à la campagne un portrait de
l'une des meilleures chanteuses
françaises
véronique sanson 30 ans et déjà une
carrière longue de 12 ans c'est dès
l'âge de 18 ans que le public français
découvre cette voix étonnante avec des
chansons dont elle écrit paroles et
musiques
à 23 ans c'est l'amérique qu'elle
découvre et de son expérience à halle en
tire une technique toute particulière la
voici de nouveau en france et après une
tournée de trois mois elle affronte le
public parisien au palais des sports et
ce depuis trois semaines cela veut dire
chaque soir sur scène où elle déploie
toute son énergie du haut de ses 1 m 60
on peut alors se demander si ces
vedettes arrive d'en avoir une vie comme
tout le monde
je crois que les gens se font une idée
de la vie de l'artiste que les gens qui
ont une vie de patachon une vie de
barreau de chaise et qui vont dans les
boîtes tous les soirs jusqu'à 5 heures
du matin ça doit exister ça existe il ya
des gens qui ont qui ont pu dire la
légende n'est pas né comme ça de rien
mais je veux dire qu'il ya des gens qui
adorent sap il ya d'autres gens qui sont
plus tournés vers une vie de vie calme
une vie de famille et une vie
complètement faux pas normal parce que
c'est pas normal d'aller jouer sur scène
tous les soirs mais je veux dire quand
c'est fini pour qu'on retrouve une vie
équilibrée normalement lloze peut-être
votre soûl pas possible or mais bien sûr
bien sûr c'est pour ça que vous êtes
retiré dans la campagne
et oui moi j'aime j'aime pas trop le
bruit des devil puisque kia ya trop de
voitures les gens deviennent agressifs
elle a pas du tout la grosse tête elle
est toujours restée simple même un tout
petit peu timide
c'est aussi difficile en étant timide de
se livrer comme cela non et ben oui mais
c'est un exorcisme en même temps je veux
dire c'est complètement paradoxal mais
c'est comme ça je ne sais pas et qu'est
ce que préférez vous dans ce métier si
vous aviez un choix à faire
moi j'aime beaucoup faire de la scène je
trouve que c'est le moment où on est
vraiment vrai et que est qui qui est
électrique complètement électrique et
vous sentez un public qui n'est pas
chaud ça se sent tout de suite leur bout
c'est pas grave on fait on sait de
prouver que messi messi il faut qu'ils
soient vraiment bien voilà alors c'est
un échange d'énergie
c'est une communication en fait un
circuit fermé
petit
je vais long cours
oui
m